All right, so welcome to our first training for genetics, and this is how we're going to look at patients, and we'll continue to add to these.
So I just pulled up the client list, the office client list on the computer, you can see it here, and we're going to pull up the sample patient.
When you pull up a patient, you can do client overview. That's how you change their name and address, send us a survey link,
which somebody just asked me to do a survey link, so I recented the survey link.
The gene report, which pulls up all the genes, and that's what we look at, many of the cancer genes that are on the regular SNP report.
NCI report, if you have that in there, SNP reports, supplement reports, really these are the two things that you're going to be looking at.
These are different lab reports. They have a thing for labrics labs, which are neurotransmitter labs.
You can look at your report history, you can look at the pyramid here, other lab work that you put in here.
You can see if the patient did their symptom survey, and if you put in these diagnosis codes, which we don't, if you're doing insurance or something like that.
So, let's go to SNP reports of this person. Then you're going to choose the SNP report.
If this is a 23 and B, and it's version three or four, then choose this practitioner report to view first.
This practitioner report is the 50-some page report or whatever it is, and then you have the copper iron and all these different reports.
So, we're going to, it's going to take a while to get through all these.
If they did version five, then you pull up these reports here.
So, I know that the sample person is a version four, so we're going to view this report first, and we'll start going through this report.
So, once you pull, once you've clicked on it and it populates up here, then you have to click on that in order for it to populate.
So, here we are, the initial reports come up variants that got in health digestion.
I never read through any of this stuff when I go through it with a patient, because I give them a copy of the practitioner report.
So, they can read through that if they want.
So, I, you know, I think the more educated the person is, the better it is for them, you know, and they'll be like, they got more on event.
When I'm going to give them this, I will hit generate report here so that it generates a PDF.
I save it to the desktop.
Then on my desktop, I have a little category called patient reports, which you should have on your desktops too, so that you have the patient reports that you saved the PDF in there.
The nice thing about this software is that it will generate with the person's last name, first name.
So, it's nice because it keeps it in an alphabetical order in that folder and you don't have to type in their name.
So, I really like that about the software too.
This is the few features like that that really help when you're trying to do something.
So, the first variants, though, remember, I always say defects, but technically they're called variants.
So, I will always go back and forth between those two terminology.
So, when you look at the report, you're looking at these variants.
So, this is an individual gene.
This is the variant.
It's either going to be a blank, which means they have no defect.
Either a leo, a one, that means they have a heterogeneous defect or a two homogeneous defect, and it doesn't get any worse than that.
And then this is the percentage of people in this software that have that same defect, that have a one on this gene.
47% of the people have a one on this gene, so it's not a very rare defect to have.
It doesn't mean it's not serious.
It just means it's not rare.
These HLA gene here have to do with gluten sensitivity.
This KIA have to do with full-blown celiac.
So, this person doesn't have any celiac genes.
Could they still have celiac though?
Yes, they could.
This person doesn't have a lot of defects in gluten sensitivity.
Could they still have gluten sensitivity?
Yes, they can.
Because gluten sensitivity, food sensitivities are really not genetic.
You could have predispositions that can predispose you to having more problems with the food, but it's really not genetic.
So, what a food sensitivity is, is you ate a food.
So, a food breaks down into its bacterial molecule.
So, gluten is what's found in...
So, you eat some bread, all right?
So, you have carbohydrates in those breads.
You have that bread, and the carbohydrate is made from wheat.
And the wheat breaks down into its protein, which is glutadine.
And glutadine is a protein.
So, a protein is a chain of amino acids.
So, you got this chain of amino acids.
Think of it as like a...
As a beaten necklace.
So, all those different beats are just amino acids.
And how it...
What makes it gleaned is the sequence of those amino acids.
It's glutamated, glycine, and alineed, and whatever amino acids that make a gleaned, this long chain of amino acids that make it into gleaned.
Now, what your digestive system is supposed to do is to create enzymes made in the pancreas that then act like scissors to snip up that chain of this...
This pearl necklace into its individual beads.
Now, an individual bead is simply an amino acid.
You're not going to develop sensitivities to an amino acid, because that's a natural thing that your body is supposed to utilize to do all sorts of things.
You need amino acids in order to do everything in your body.
That's what makes up enzymes are amino acids.
And so, those are amino acids in a bead shade of one amino acid, one little bead, or another bead connected to another bead, which is called a dipeptide-e2 amino acids together.
That's as big as it's supposed to be to be able to get across the gut board.
Nothing larger than a dipeptide is supposed to get across the gut board.
If your gut is breaking it down, let's say the chain of gleaned and I don't know how many amino acids are in a gleaned.
But let's say it's 100.
The enzymes come up and they start sniping it into groups of 15, 12, and 40, and 12, and 5, and sniping it up.
But your gut border, your intestinal wall is damaged from adiabatic use, from exposure to GMOs, from eating a bunch of flavorings, additives, colorings, chemicals, all sorts of bad fats, etc.
So, the border of your gut is damaged, things could get across in a larger molecular size than it should.
So, now, instead of just a single amino acid for a dipeptide, two amino acids combined together, get it across.
Now, it's going across at a chain of five. That's called a peptide, so any piece of a protein is a peptide.
Down to a single amino acid, it's just an amino acid. So, you got these peptides of chains of 12, and 15, and 40, and 32.
Getting across the gut border, and the more damage there is to the gut border, the larger the peptide will cross.
So, that gets into the bloodstream, and your immune system sees that in your bloodstream, it says, what the sand blazes is that?
And it says, we need to kill it. So, it creates an antibody against that peptide.
Well, will that peptide die if that antibody connects to that peptide so that the T cell, the immune system responds, can kill it?
No, it's not an amino organism. So, what's your immune system supposed to do? Your immune system kills things.
That's all your immune system doesn't, you know, escort it out of the body. All it does is kill things.
So, if your immune system is supposed to fire against bacteria that cross the gut border, or viruses, or bone, or fungus, or you got bit by a mosquito, and there's bacteria in the mosquito bite that got jacked into your bloodstream.
So, not just crossing the gut border, but you breathe in a virus from somebody who has a cold, and that's how it gets into the bloodstream.
That's how your immune system is supposed to fire against living things, creates an antibody against it, attaches to that living thing.
So, your killer side of your immune system can kill that thing, or readily.
But when you start making antibodies to foods that aren't living, okay, it's just a set of amino acids, you create this cascade of an immune response
that now you have a sensitivity quote unquote, which is simply a sensitivity is heightened allergic response because you've made antibodies to that thing.
And now every time you eat that gliadid, it breaks down to those peptides and you have a beetle, if you have antibodies against those things, you fire this immune response in the gut cavity, because you have antibodies in the gut cavity.
And in the bloodstream, and you have a quote unquote allergic reaction, which is simply an immune response because you had a damaged gut border originally.
So does that have to do with genetics? Yes and no. So this will give you precursors to a greater tendency to have gliadid issues, but really I don't talk about this really at all with patients.
Because it's not really about genetics with that, it's about get back to the damage gut. You could have this, I know who this sample person is, and this sample person has severe reactions to gluten.
And he's off-gluten, but he if he does equal to his severe reactions to gluten, and so you look at their genetics and it doesn't even look like they have any issues.
Because there really is nothing to do with genetics. So we're going to talk about dietary things, we really are looking at this.
But with every patient, should we talk about dietary things? Well, really everything really boils down to that, right? The health of the gut, you could argue, is the most important thing.
So, and understand any of these genetic defects these people have had since birth, and it is environmental things that really cause a person to have these genetic dysfunctions.
Now, this caffeine metabolism defect, it's believed to be that this specific site of protein 450g, if you have variants of this gene, you actually metabolize caffeine more quickly.
So, if a person has a 2 here, coffee makes them pee.
So, before we had this genetic picture to look at, I used to ask people, could I drink coffee, I'd say, just coffee make you pee. Yes, I have to run around for a drink coffee. Well, then you could drink coffee, because you would metabolize it quite quickly.
But no, I get a whole pile of coffee, I'd ever have to pee. Well, then you shouldn't be drinking coffee, because the effect of the caffeine is going to be in your body for a long period of time, and it could have ill effects.
But you can also look at this, if a person has a 2 here, they could drink, you know, probably 3, 4 or 5 cups of coffee a day, they're fine.
First of all, one here, you can have a couple cups of coffee a day, probably if they have a 0, you probably should live at their half cup, or maybe a couple of coffee a day.
Still, this BCOG is under got, but we can actually put this BCOG under other categories as well.
The BCOG has to do with your ability to absorb and utilize and process a very important fat soluble vitamin A, that we tend to take for granted.
Because we don't have people walking around saying, oh, hi, my name's Joe, I have vitamin A deficiency.
But we have a lot of people that have a vitamin A deficiency.
And the source of vitamin A in so many nutrients is a synthetic source, which is not good for us.
It could cause even more problems.
So we're going to actually actually do a video on vitamin A.
I was hoping it would get done last week, but I got to get that done soon too.
It ties to this BCOG.
And you can see like this person has a lot of defects in their BCOG.
Now it's tied to, it's put in the category of got issues.
Because the vitamin A is so essential for epithelial tissue health.
Your epithelial tissue.
So histologically, you have different cell lines.
And if your epithelial cell line has to, that's what makes up your skin of your body.
You could say, oh, my outside skin.
Yes, but the skin of your lungs, the skin of your gut, the skin of your organs.
Is all made up of different types of epithelial tissue.
The skin of your arteries is epithelial tissue.
So this BCOG is under looked at, we could say.
This is very important.
This is, this could be a huge precursor to gut problems.
And a reason why a person's gut is not healing.
Doing all this stuff for my gut.
I'm thinking probiotics and prebiotics.
That's data way from blue to the dairy.
And my diet is so clear, they can hardly eat it.
They can't figure out why I can't get my gut better.
Well, this is a key missing piece.
A lot of these people is a good whole foods for a vitamin A.
Okay.
With vitamin K.
With you big one all.
Just cook you 10.
And some other good forms of vitamin D can be really helpful and healing to the gut.
So we're actually getting a new product with many of those things in that we'll talk about that we'll address with this.
Now, understand, you could look at this, this profile here.
And you can see this gene, they have no defect.
60.2% of the people in this software have no defect.
Now, remember the 25,000 plus people that are in this software is not a healthy cohort study of 25,000 healthy college students.
This is 25,000 people who ran their genetics and wanted to go to a doctor who really dug in depth with it.
They probably had some serious health problems.
I can't say my disease is serious issues.
Okay.
So that's so understand take that into account when we look at the percentages.
So when you look at these percentages.
Oh, well, this is quite common that most people don't have a defect.
This is not like uncommon that people have a one here.
So you look at some of these.
Well, here gets a little more uncommon, having a two there.
It's these are pretty common, pretty common.
This is real uncommon, 8.3%.
The person has a one there.
Common, common, common.
Oh, well, these are very uncommon defects.
Yeah, but we're looking at each individual defect.
How do you look at it as the as a whole?
Where did this where does this person rank with all their BC emoji defects?
Then you could click on this little thing here.
And as a patient, when you get a copy of the PDF of this,
you don't have that interactive software.
But with the software, you can look at this and see this craft.
And when we look at this craft, here's the mean of the people in the 25,000 people in this population software.
We'd ever really want to be to the right of the beat.
Because remember, if we had a healthy cohort study,
the mean would be somewhere over here.
So we'd really rather be to the left of the beat.
We don't even want to be at the beat.
We don't want to be as sick as everybody else sick, who's sick to this thing, right?
We want to be healthier than the sick people in this program.
And when we're to the right of the beat, we're sicker than the sick people.
That's not good.
So this person has issues worse than the most people do with the BC emoji.
And the FUT2 genes.
So how would you support this?
This is one that I may want to support.
Notice how it has these boxes here, these different genes.
There's some things, there's some boxes up here.
How would you support gut health with gluten issues?
Well, of course, dietary.
You've got to take them off gluten and things like that.
But there's products like GI assist, histamine scavenger, decrease histamine in the gut.
Does this have anything to do with histamine in the gut?
No, but if they have a lot of defects here, if they have a gliadinsensitivity,
and every time they eat gliadins, they're going to have more inflammation in the gut,
using a histamine scavenger, or better, would be using something that has DAO enzyme in it itself.
Because if you look at histamine scavenger,
if you click on this box here, you can pull up the PDF of what's in that product.
If you look at histamine scavenger, it has ALO in it.
That's going to be very healing for the gut.
Of course, it didn't grow the lead, it didn't leave this in sticky dental.
These could be good anti-inflammatories.
Pine bark extract could be a good colbin in a pain relief.
And that's a CH2 stimulant that colbs that immune response.
Marshmallow root could be colbin, bitter horde, licorice,
or the deglycerized licorice could be very colbin to the gut.
So these can be extremely colbin to the gut, right?
It close out of that, close that.
But we may want, if they have increased histamine production of the gut,
you may want to choose something that has the DAO enzyme in it,
which is the enzyme that will break down histamine of the gut,
if that's what your purpose is.
Or you may want to go with another digestive enzyme,
just to help with digestive things.
And that's where you'd get to the supplement report on a person.
And so, got issues, what am I going to use?
Well, none of those are in the software, so you'd have to hit add a supplement,
and go down, no, I'm over the years, added a bunch of digestive enzymes supplements.
And so you could go to, you'd have to know what you're looking for.
So I will create that form to look for things,
but a little slow here,
but you go to a digestive enzyme of some sort.
So here's digestive enzymes right there.
You might think that, right?
Let's close that.
We're getting ahead of ourself.
So let's go back to the SNIP report,
which is this right here.
So the next gene is the FUT2G.
The FUT2G is very important genes,
because this is how you make muterate,
which is the main fuel source for your larger tested,
and it can help also with the fuel of the epidelial cells of the small intestine as well.
So the FUT2G is important with gut health,
that's why it's under this category.
And this person has probably no more G defects than the average,
you can click on this, and they're a little bit better than average here,
which is good.
This was really bad for them, but this is a little bit better.
But defects in this, this populates proflora,
which is a probiotic.
So it'd be good this person to have a probiotic,
would it be ever good for almost every human being to be taking a probiotic?
Yeah, maybe.
GI assist.
What's a GI assist?
Oh, I forgot.
Let's look it up.
So you could look it up, and you could see,
oh, it's droid, no tissue, stomach tissue,
peppermint leaf, which could be called into the gut.
A green cabbage, which could be healing to the gut a little again.
And these are anti-inflammatory and some digestive enzymes.
Oh, here's one with digestive enzymes in it.
Yeah.
So this could be a good product to use.
This new probiotic, this great gut brain symbiotic,
is a new probiotic that was out that has some very specific probiotics
for gut brain health,
because, okay, side track a little bit.
Remember, when I always say anything that happens in the gut,
happens in the brain, that's rule number one.
You have inflammation in the gut,
you have inflammation in the brain.
That's why you have any patient that comes in that has any mood issues,
any ADD, any ADHD issues,
any anger, any OCD,
any type of things that you would generally think to look at the biopterid pathway
that will get into it a little bit,
with the production of neurotransmitters.
If they have anything that's causing inflammation of the gut,
you're going to have inflammation of the brain.
There is a gluteo-borphine connection
and a KCO-borphine connection.
If I have glutein sensitivities or KC,
which is the protein in dairy,
if I have dairy or glutein sensitivities,
it's going to fire directly to the brain.
It fires the receptors in the brain that are the save receptors for more feet.
So, no wonder these kids have behavioral issues,
when all their eat is breaded chicken nuggets,
French fries and pizza,
which is dairy and glutein together.
But that's all you'll eat,
but you're the parent.
I know, but that's all he'll eat.
He won't eat anything else.
Okay.
He will eat something else,
or he will starve to death.
And he won't starve to death.
So, he will eat as vegetables.
If someone has happened to parent-team,
but that was my parents,
you're going to say to his table tell you eat that.
And if we did eat it,
we went in a refrigerator.
That was for supper tomorrow.
But no, we don't want to affect our kids.
And we want them to like us and we want them to be our friends,
so we give them what they want,
and then we have to deal with the behavior.
So, then, we run up to doctors and say,
there's something wrong.
It must be their genes.
So, it's not the genes.
they may have genes that look like this, but you could give them all the supplements of the world
until their eyes turned green and it's still not going to help but tell you to change that
inflammatory process that's taking place in the gut. Right? So FUT2 genes. Now here's some that is
pre-populated by favorite to help support these pathways of the gut pathways if you want to help
other than diet is sunspectrum. So sunspectrum is a product that has the prebiotics, the probiotics
together with a good tetrahedral curcumidoid. So the curcumidoid is that piece of turmeric that
helps decrease inflammation in the gut. It also has the best form of uvincuinal, which is co-Q10,
which helps heal the gut. So that is a great product that is very healing to the gut.
Then you get into some other gut genes. These ABP1 family of genes here is how you make the DAO
enzyme, which is essential for brachydone histamine in the gut. Now why would you have histamine in the gut?
Well you have histamine in the gut for two reasons. You eat foods that have histamine in it,
which are like salami and even strawberries and dried meat. There's a whole list of histamine
foods. I mean a lot of foods with a lot of really good foods have histamine in it. Well what's
problem with that? Well really nothing. If you have a genetic picture that looks like this,
so this person has any defects in here. So this person makes that DAO and I quite well
to break down histamines in their food. So even really good foods like fermented foods that are
a lot of probiotics like kombucha has a lot of good probiotics. It's really good for your gut.
But if the person has two two two two here, they should be drinking any of that stuff for
these. They should really be on a very low histamine diet because they can't break it down
or they could take a DAO enzyme every time to eat that stuff. Problem with that the DAO enzyme
products are real eat expensive. So that's a really long term solution. The other way that you
get histamine in the gut is because you have a food sensitivity you're not dealing with.
So well I know I should be off-aggluted but I really like cupcakes. So I'm going to eat a
bit of it. Well then well good luck with that because every time you eat it you're causing
an immune reaction with the gut and the heart of that immune reaction is going to be production
of history. It's only part of it. So even if I could, oh then I'm just going to take a DAO enzyme
every time I eat my cupcake. Well that's not solving your problem because you may be reducing the
histamine in your gut but you're not reducing the T cell activation and your macrophage activation
and the damage that you're doing to the rest of the tissue and all it's the molecular
mimics in your body as well. So but if a person has defects on this pathway here, these
this family of genes, then you want to definitely limit the amount of histamine they're eating.
histamine that they're consuming and also push them to baby do some other testing
that would pin points on food sensitivities especially if they're having a lot of symptoms
that are tied to gut function. Well what would those be? Oh I don't have a stomach ache,
I don't have any problems. I have a bowel move but every day and I don't have any gut problems whatsoever.
I just have this really bad acne. That's a gut problem. I just have this, you know, OCD issue.
That's a gut problem. I just have some agarations. That's a gut problem. I just have skin rashes. That's
a gut problem. I just have cancer. That's gut problem. We can just go on up here, right? I'm sorry but
everything stems from the gut. Does it mean the gut causes every disease? No, but it's
tied to everything. So what are some other tests that you would run to determine gut problems?
Yes. So you run the like favorite tests, it's the cyrox test because it measures the different
peptides. So a lot of test people will go, no, no, no, that's not me. I have this blood test. I had
a blood test done and gluten, I don't have problem with gluten. You have to ask, oh, well, that's
neat. Can I see the blood test? And many times it will be just a general blood test in the measured
antibodies to glee added. Okay, remember, glee added is the entire pearl necklace.
How bad does your gut have to be that the entire pearl necklace got across it in order for you to
form antibodies against it? I mean, like, you can get much worse than that, right? So you can't
look at that because a person typically will not have antibodies to the entire pearl necklace to glee added.
They'll have antibodies to the peptides, the pieces, the sections, the set of 50, the set of 12. And
cyrox is the only lab currently that measures peptide interaction. Follow me. So that's why it's
important to look at that. So people will go, oh, no, I had, but I thought I was gluten too. So I
stopped eating it. I felt better. My doctor said I should do a test. So I did the test that came back
negative. So it went back to eating it. Your doctor said nobody's talking about it. So you can't
look at the glee. And everybody solely took glee add you have to look at antibodies to the peptides
as well. And the same thing goes for KC and some of the other large proteins that you're measuring with
food sensitivities to. The cyrox panel 10 measures, I think 300 different foods that people can develop
sensitivities to, to, to very common, they have set 70s to some of the gluten ingredients in gluten
three products. So they can be gluten three. It's still can't figure out why they can't get their gut
better. Well, it can be a vitamin A issue with this. It could be a problem with your FUT2 genes,
but very, very common. It's, they have sensitivities to tapioca flour and have sensitivities to the
sonoma, they have sensitivities to these two other things that are in gluten free ingredients.
That's the beauty of that cyrox 10 panel is that can pinpoint that. And then you get this giant aha
moment. Oh my gosh, I beat that all the time. And they cut that out and they address these issues
that are in here. And they just like turn the court. Okay. So those are difficult patients if they
won't really address those things that you really can't really get them better. It's very difficult.
And then this gene, the H-N-M-T gene is how you break down it has to be in a tissue.
So this is a tissue, it has to be. So a histamine that is in the gut, do you absorb that? Yes,
you can. When you make the DAO enzyme in the gut to break down histamine, do you absorb that? No,
you don't. If I take a whole bunch of DAO enzyme capsules because they are on the market, we have
them in our store. But they can be really good to call them this time. But if I take a bunch of
those, will I help decrease histamine in my tissue? No, you won't because you don't absorb those.
So that's where you have to use a product like histamine scavenger or other anti-flammatory products.
Perkyman, Boswellia, Chorsentin, Stiggy, Dettles. Those are anti-inflammatories. They help pull
histamine out of the body. And the H-N-M-T gene is what makes the DAO enzyme in the tissue
to get rid of histamine. Because histamine is not, we think of histamine as a bad guy. Remember,
in all of biochemistry, there's no bad guy, good guy. They all have a purpose.
histamine has a very important purpose in the immune response, and it's therefore a reason,
but then you need to be able to break it down and get rid of it. So when you don't break it down,
you get rid of it. Then you have a problem. Okay, let's go to the oxalate genes.
These are important genes as well. You oxalates are another biochemical that's in foods. It's
really good foods. It's in spinach, in kale, in rhubarb, and other things. But it doesn't serve a
traditional value to us. We're not supposed to absorb it. We're supposed to break it down
through these genes and expel it into the toilet. If we have a lot of defects in here,
then we are going to absorb an increase about of oxalates, and that could cause all sorts of
problems. Matter of fact, people that are prone to kidney stones have defects here.
Before we could look at these genes, we would ask just family history questions. Does your father
and mother have kidney history of kidney stones? Yes, they do. My dad had a bunch of kidney stones.
Well, most likely you have defects in these oxalate genes, and we should use a product to help
pull that out. If we have defects in those genes, and we want to use a product with
called oxalate scavenger, that could help pull it out of our body. A little bit of vitamin D helps.
This is a K2 product. It's not a whole lot of K2, but that helps balance that.
Calcium citrate and magnesium orate in the gut help bind oxalate.
So that can help bind oxalates and get rid of it. This also has a little bit of a spore probiotic.
And the difference between that and the oxalate balancer is,
and this is still not the calcium and magnesium. It adds a zinc to it. And this has some other
herbs in it that can pull it out of the tissue once you absorb it. So oxalate scavenger is
meant to help scavenger in the gut so that you don't absorb it as well. Balancer is someone who has
a lot of defects in here that you want to help pull it out of their tissue. So they have kidney
studs and such. And they've already have studed for more studed formation that I would use the
balancer as opposed to the scavenger. All right, so let's close that here. Other lab tests that
you may want to run in this section, I would definitely say the Syrex panel. You could also use
a judova gut stool sample test. So judova labs has a stool sample test because you could be
dealing with. So there got issues. Could it be dietary due to sensitivities, food that we
discussed that late? Yes. So that's where the Syrex panel would test for that. Find out that.
Could it be that they have a testicle parasites?
Sure. They could have had that for 10 years since they went to a foreign country, a mission trip 10
years ago. That would be picked up. You know, even though those tests are perfect, that would be picked
up through a Syrex or a judova stool sample test. Also judova has and some other labs have a test that
measures the 2,200 I think it is. It's 2,205 of judova. Hasn't is a test that also measures
probiotic balance. So if they're if their balance is the different feelings that probiotics are way
off, it will show that. Also, they have a test that measures amino acid balance and essential fatty
acid balance. Central fatty acids are important for gut health as well. So if they're way off,
if they're essential fatty acid balance, that's an issue. Other history things that are really
important with gut health is have really covered have they had gallbladder surgery. So if they have
removed their gallbladder, remember what the gallbladder does, it stores bio secreted by the liver.
And then it is secreted by the gallbladder when the person eats fatty food. And one of the
vials, one of the purposes of biol is to help break their fat. So it helps bite fat in the gut.
So if you don't have a gallbladder, they'll just have to trickle a bile for the liver into the slow
and tested constantly. Whether they have fat in their gut and when they eat a meal that has a lot of
fat, they only have a trickle of bile there to break those fat and that can cause a lot of problems
with people. Especially when you're putting them on good fats that will help heal the gut.
So if they don't have a gallbladder and you put them on a good fat diet with coconut oil or you put
them on a product with phospholipids to help them make bile, that's a fatty substance. Or you put
them on any of the fat soluble vitamins, like a good vitamin A or vitamin D or vitamin E,
then they might have difficulty breaking that down and you may have to use another product that has
Oxfile in it. So we have several products that have Oxfile in it that you may want to give the patient
when they eat a meal. And don't forget digestive enzymes as a made product with this
and product with hydrochloric acid in it because a deficiency in HCl production of the stomach can
throw everything on. So that could be maybe the number one deficiency in America. Because of people
taking, you know, antacids, artificial calories and flavorings and GMOs affect stomach acid production.
They don't have stomach acid if enough to break down carbohydrates. They have carbohydrates
going into the smaller intestine. They are much larger molecules than they should and makes just
puts a lot of stress on the gut. So those are some other things that you want to look at with
testing and other products that you want to look at with gut health. All right,
that's the gut section. We'll have that there.